[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits season two I'm
Rhett and I'm link joining us today and
kicking off our new season is TV star
and Internet tone setter Rainn Wilson
yes we are happy to have him at the
roundtable of dim lighting and I'm happy
to be back here with you link at the
round table of them like oh yeah and
thank you for being here with us
bringing your ears to be biscuit 'add
yeah
the the lighting is dim or dimmed that
was the funny thing was a second ago
right now were just discussing maybe
we're a little rusty but I refer to it
as the roundtable of dim delighting and
then you were like hold on we've never
caught it at its did it's the round
table of dim lighting dee I am NOT di mm
Edie but you might be technically
correct I mean is dim a word or is it
always dimmed is it like stupid lighting
you think is what that the implication
is I'm gonna go with them it is well
that means we're gonna stick with it
because that's what we've been doing but
it doesn't mean stupid it just means
dimmed but it is a lot different in here
in this room because we used to be semi
surrounded by the good mythical morning
set which is now moved to the new
building we are in transition if you
watch good mythical morning you already
know this but we're moving into a new
building but it's not happening quickly
and it's not just because it takes a
long time to move but there's work being
done at the new building you're right
the round table has not moved from its
original location under the unmoved dim
lighting the dim light in it so it kind
of feels like empty in here it's almost
like we're in a like an abandoned
doctor's office like a weird doctor that
did bad things to people that's what I
feel like this room feels like just that
like he would he would like conduct
experiments on people yeah well the
reason I'm thinking that is because I
watched this we're watching a the black
list on Netflix and last night episode
was about this nurse that was taking
people into his home and inflicting
injuries upon them the same injuries
they inflicted on other people he was
very it wasn't thought it was a
difficult episode to watch and now I
feel like our studio looks like that
place where that guy tortures people hmm
what kind of tone is that set well I
haven't watched you know I'm not gonna
watch that show but you wanted I told
you what I've been watching Vikings yeah
on Amazon because it's go yes on Amazon
Prime and there's some disturbing
violent stuff in that show I'll just go
ahead and tell you if you if you're
saying it with a smile on your face
there's lots of blood and like acts work
lots of Acts working on my ex work so
but I I'm into it
I I like it well let's check in that out
keep just talking about the shows are
watching but we had it we felt you felt
the need to apologize to rain when he
came in here about our place we started
playing into it like how bad it was we
care about the aesthetic I mean we care
about aesthetics it's like he knew no
different I mean you know exactly if you
didn't apology
you know exactly at your point he thinks
we work in a doctor's office torture
chamber I don't want him to think that
about us what well I think you cleared
it out okay repeated apology okay well
we were played in - super excited to
have rain on the show and to kick off
season 2 of course you already know rain
as Dwight the pompous assistant to the
regional manager on the Emmy winning
sitcom the office what is my perfect
crime I break into Tiffany's in midnight
do I go for the vault no I go for the
chandelier it's priceless as I'm taking
it down a woman catches me she tells me
to stop it's her father's business
she's Tiffany I say no we make love all
night in the morning the cops come and I
escape in one of their uniforms I tell
her to meet me in Mexico but I go to
Canada I don't trust her besides I like
the cold thirty years later I get a
postcard I have a son and he's the Chief
of Police this is where the story gets
interesting
I tell Tiffany to meet me in Paris by
the Trocadero she's been waiting for me
all these years she's never taken
another lover I don't
I don't show up I go to Berlin that's
where I stashed the chandelier okay but
before he was Dwight Rayne spent many
years on stage in the New York theater
scene on Broadway doing all types of
stuff worked just he the dude's got
chops after he made his move to LA he
started to get film and TV traction
his first big recurring role was on
HBO's Six Feet Under
I actually haven't seen that yeah but I
bet it's got some ax work in it or some
blood work it's in between kind of like
well those people are dead I watched a
little no Joe
of course then he moved on to the TV
behemoth the office for nine seasons I
remember that one oh yeah I mean being
very obsessed with that show I think at
one point I know at one point in the
conversation with the rain I went into a
little Dwight and he called me on it and
I didn't realize I was doing it you know
it's just a subconscious thing when
you're when you're talking to a guy that
you've watched on television all these
years right in your and you're kind of
being self-conscious you're like I know
that he's known as Dwight but I don't
want to make it seem like I feel like
I'm talking to Dwight and I feel like I
did that you didn't you didn't do it
well but I feel like at least one of us
did you're joking right
you did fine okay good and we need to
know that I did okay and we in
particular were really interested in
talking about SoulPancake
it was kind of where our worlds meet on
the Internet
that's his website slash book slash
YouTube channel that he co-created that
he describes as a place where young
people can connect to talk about life's
big questions so and you get this if you
have ever heard rain talk just candidly
you know outside of one of his
characters you already know this but
you're gonna learn it today he's a
thoughtful philosophical guy he has a
very strong worldview and thinks about
things deeply we were fascinated to
discuss that and also talked about his
Baha'i faith which he's been really
public about and also to discuss the
intriguing animals that are his family
pets so that may or may not be links
favorite animal yeah my mind gets blown
at a certain point and he
but life after the office I think the
bottom line is that it's looking good
for rain Backstrom his new TV show just
premiered on Fox Thursdays at 9:00 DVR
it we'd like to thank me undies for
helping to make this episode of ear
biscuits possible you may remember me
talking about me undies oh yeah last
season passionately and I will say that
since that point I have slowly but
surely replaced every single pair of
underwear in my underwear drawer that
was not a me undies pair and now my
entire drawer is all me undies I'm not
making this up these are the most
comfortable thing you can put on your
body well especially underwear maybe it
it all you know including anything you
could put on your body but definitely
underwear Christie got me something for
Christmas and I was I was really pumped
so we're happy to have them as a sponsor
bomani have styles for men and women my
mom got me some other kinds of underwear
for Christmas and I took him straight to
the thrift store don't tell my mom I
don't think she listens to here but know
what hmm my mom got me some too and I
couldn't do that so I'm wearing them a
little bit but I think I'm gonna go
they're eradication route just like you
and you should to go to me undies comm
slash rhett and Link and get 20% off
your first order and free shipping
people you can save even more when you
buy a pack of them but yeah me undies
calm slash rhett and Link get that 20%
we also want to take a second to help
you get prepared for Valentine's Day
because that's coming up if your
sweetheart says she doesn't want
anything for Valentine's Day that is
code for get me something for
Valentine's Day and listen don't get her
a potted plant I made the mistake of
getting my wife a potted plant not roses
but a potted plant since to me she said
that's the most unromantic thing you've
ever done for me ouch
but it lives forever it doesn't wilt I
don't know either way but we have a
solution this year because we're bad at
this we're assuming that many of you are
very bad at this berries dot-com go to
Sherry's berries get giant freshly
dipped strawberries they got a
strawberry big big strawberries dipped
in white chocolate milk chocolate dark
chocolate at the top with chocolate
chips something to call a decorative
swizzle link you can get a decorative
swizzle all these various swizzle on
mine is
or I don't know what that means that's
not their slogan they didn't ask me for
that and I shouldn't have offered it
strawberry's good chocolate good put the
two together add some swizzle on my
nizzle and there you go I don't know
where you're going with that but
assortments start at $19.99 that's over
40% savings go to Barry's comm click on
the microphone and type in our code
rhett and Link and they'll know that we
sent you and you can also use that to
double your berry order the number of
berries for just $10 more yeah click on
the microphone rhett and Link dot not
Ren Ling calm let's go to berries dot
can you do that we're not selling
berries on our website yet we don't have
the capability to put swizzle on
anybody's nizzle so go to berries ber RI
es calm and then use our code rhett and
Link now enjoy our air biscuit with
Rainn Wilson
I was just apologizing for how lame this
place is you guys are really there's so
many I walk in here and there's so many
apologies happening really face just
like yeah it pretty much sucks here it's
pretty it's pretty awful and bear moans
din and lame but it's okay man it's okay
like a ward but look that way it's DIY
man it's punk rock okay YouTube oh yeah
that's hot cast comedy man joy
anti-establishment the man I kind of
rhettandlink kind of bolt up in here and
Burbank okay feel L mr. king
can you feel his stare because we left
him I love Elvis I my son is 10 years
old he used to be obsessed with Elvis
because we had the Elvis channel on the
Sirius XM so we would listen to hell
this guy came into school so preschool
kindergarten first grade he just loved I
knew all the songs sang along because
you liked Elvis you listened to it and
he just assumed that was using about any
channels that we listened to and then
but he would always request all of us
he's got a good taste yeah and
now he likes imagine dragons no well I
have a ten-year-old it's really super
all the 10 year olds the imagine driver
yes he every ten year old you have a
nine year old son so we're all in the
same okay good now my son huge imagine
dragons fan but he was just telling me
he's gotten into this stage where he
begins talking and I'm like you sound
like an adult like the way that you're
forming your cynicism your opinions very
adult he's like then I'm not gonna get
that I'm not gonna get the new album
I've just been disappointed he's already
sounds like he lives in Silver Lake
disappointed with yeah did he finish
their live performances or haven't been
to their new songs are not as good as
their old song yeah right yeah we should
go just like our videos your our old
videos always tend to be better than our
new and according to the comments yeah
funny like you used to be known I could
tell you a funny rhett and Link story
yes you don't know that we had a street
yeah let's do that give us some history
oh this is good so I'm gonna say I'm
still trying to figure out why you're
here on five um for your own sake I love
I love Burbank I love all these streets
out here and Brad likes the victory
straightness oh yeah yeah that's just
like sun-baked
it's there's an old 'no Stu I love it
out yeah right I love it out here
no so I'm gonna say five or six years
ago when did you guys have your very
first viral video but the car the car
dealership or the furniture store yeah
the red house furniture Red House for ya
oh my is that oh nine right yeah yep oh
so right when that came out I saw it and
I emailed everyone on at my agency and I
have my management company I'm like you
guys sign these guys immediately really
these guys are super super talented I am
not I'm not making this up I'm not
booking you for real I did that and they
all won't like look that and like yeah
that's pretty funny I don't know really
what we do with them
like they're so funny that there's got
to be something you can do them I mean
um that's as far as it went but I just
want to let you know that I was well
thank you for the effort from the get-go
Wow I wish we had like a reciprocal
story for you it's all right so I
watched you on television and I thought
many times that it was great I made a
lot of phone calls Oh was that you yeah
I'm sure I told family members
throughout the years to watch like the
office and sure okay okay you don't need
to pay me back it doesn't need to be
quid pro quo well just give me a price
I'm $1400 okay okay what are some rice
for I don't get it is that the time
value of money I don't know what the
price what's the price where the for the
plug to the ER agents and people Oh
$1,400 okay okay do you remember the
time value of money did I never I never
understood that now what is it I don't
know this is seventh grade well it's
inflation I guess it had something to do
with inflation and it was it was okay
well this is $1400 and o.9 but it's oh
right now yeah the time valium that's an
actual thing that yeah yeah it's like
you're learning we owe you like two
grand oh no I was assuming he already
took that into account oh okay 1,400 now
we met like the first time that we
actually met and shook hands was on a
plane well as a year ago on a plane -
son - yeah and you know we you run the
beautiful Burbank Airport you were doing
a show there and Sundance we were
YouTube had it's like own set up there
and we did a QA okay so we went to
Sundance is great but so we were we saw
you in the Burbank Airport
okay stalker I think you were with your
with your family my wife and son you
know so we gave you your space then
Leonard Maltin was also waiting to get
on that plane fantastic and Rockwell
right Rockwell was on era he said across
from me right and so then we're walking
on you sat down first and then the you
you past rain yes and but then I stopped
and said hello
oh and that was our meeting this is this
is a great story and then it gets better
I start
and said hello it gets worth telling a
little bit here a good so then we
weren't sitting together I was sitting
with Sam Rockwell's yeah the thing that
really got me was I was looking over at
Sam and he was reviewing a script he was
memorizing his lines and tell anyone
about him but at a certain point we got
into a conversation I started talking
about his technique and he was listening
to he was listening to a read-through of
his lines that was his technique for
learning his lines was listening to them
repeatedly in kind of a monotone on acti
kind of a way which I understand is an
actress like me for learning oh and
lines so we select mean to the other
people queuing the line no he was just
listening to himself he reading he had
two versions he had himself himself
monotone and then he had a dialect like
a southern dialect guy read it which is
dialect from Tennessee right so he owns
a funeral home that his dialect coach
found and got him to read the script
some funeral home owners like Alabama we
even know what this movie is um it's a
Jared Hess movie Jared Hess movie that I
don't know what's happening with it but
he's a biblical archaeologist oh yeah
you kind of tongue-in-cheek I think it
sounded hilarious hmm but it you know I
was just fascinating kind of watching
him work he was he was Sam was listening
to the guy he let me listen to it it was
hilarious and he's you know he's
underlining certain words and then
circling in other words and it was
almost like his printed out script
became this scribble of kind of
something I would want to keep if you
know I took it from him but I'm I'm
wondering like for you I know you got
like a theater background what's your
technique how do you how do you learn
lines cuz literally I googled cuz I
can't learn lines for crap do you Google
how to lie mines
I googled you learn like and that's
where I read about the audio listening
thing that Sam was doing and that's why
I knew what he was doing cuz I googled
it a few months earlier you've never
done that I have never done that what I
have done some times before is read the
other people's lines and leave a space
for my lines okay so I can hear the cues
yeah because I'm more I don't
here my lines I want to hear the other
people's lines so then I respond
accordingly I don't I wouldn't know what
to do with that technique and that's why
they it's red monotone so at least you
don't get like the acting cue right and
you get into some ditch of well this is
I gotta say it like a right maybe I
should try that a divin think I'm gonna
try it I'm for real but you you don't
have a problem but how do you remember
what you're gonna say in those gaps just
whatever well I have like the script and
I'll kind of be half on half off just
kind of saying them you know what I mean
because to me I think there's this weird
thing about repetition and if you just
say the lines a ton a ton of times like
it really it does really help and you
say and make sure you say it in a lot of
different ways don't just say it the
same way every time that's one thing
that helps me is just repetition just
going through it the script or saying it
out loud saying and saying and saying it
um it's you know it really is like
what's my technique I don't this is a
heavy question I don't really have a
technique per se on the office it was
pretty easy because it was short scenes
and usually you didn't have to memorize
a ton you could improvise and kind of go
off the script and and and go crazy and
it was super super fun in that way
Backstrom is was so hard this new TV
show because yeah yeah I'm the lead of
it and it's an hour-long TV show and I
would have seven or eight pages of
dialogue per day to to work on and I'd
have to work
I'd memorize a scene or two at night
before mm-hm and then I'd memorize a
scene like driving in and going through
makeup so then by that point I'd have
two or three of the scenes memorized and
then I'd like memorize one at lunch you
know so it's constantly memorizing but
so that was a little bit different but
the first this time on Backstrom was the
first time I ever worked with an acting
coach so that was crazy
this guy Larry Moss who's a very famous
acting coach and yeah I mean you got a
lot of experience some what led to get
an acting coach well this one
specifically because I was going from
the office and then two weeks later I
was shooting a really complicated
character there was an alcoholic and
he's it
addicted to all these different things
and he's self-hating and he's kind of
twisted and he has a very warped
worldview and so it was it was a lot of
work and yet and also like a cop like I
you know I'm this pudgy suburban
character comedy guile and you know and
I don't you know how am I gonna be
believable as a cop like how does this
work do I want to act like a cop I just
wanna but I want it to feel real but I
don't want to put on anything and I
don't want to you know there was a
danger with the role that it could be
kind of like one of those who is that
guy in NYPD Blue
Caruso no the other guy the tough guy
with the pockmarked face oh yeah the one
who the guy that always gets them to
know that he's got his hair on the side
of his head yeah yeah the bald guy is
really craggly faced guy google him you
have computers yes we do we do guys
that'll be rude no that's that's what we
should be doing um I don't want to lose
my tab how to remember my lines I don't
want out it up yeah I don't want to
Google anything else yeah I had it but
you didn't want to be him um you're are
you googling it right I gave up but
apparently someone upstairs is uploading
a video to YouTube we adorable you would
think that guys who make you to everyone
listening right now is going we'll just
edit that I don't know how are you
talking about I'm gonna tell you and I'm
gonna tell you in less than seven
seconds okay Dennis Franz Dennis Franz
that's it and everyone listening I do
not know that I blanked senior moment
okay but I didn't want to be like Dennis
Franz a tough cop guy and I didn't want
to be like there's just a lot of there
were a lot of pitfalls to be had and the
character of Backstrom when you're
playing like a a messed up police
detective tough-talking self-hating
it was easy traps to fall into and I
didn't want to fall into them and I
wanted to and I also really wanted to
make sure that I was doing it very
different than Dwight that there wasn't
any any aroma of Dwight and them all in
and playing the character so it worked
with this guy was really cool and was
there like one big take away like in a
moment of Epiphany or was it just more
of like walking through the paces with
this coach and you arrived somewhere I
think that the there was a big take away
it's a pretty basic acting thing but he
was really on me about you how does this
guy see the world I see the world
through his eyes and how did he get that
way so he sees the world through his
eyes in that way so it's really all
about like how does he see the world and
how did he get that way so it was a lot
of internal adjustments to think to
think about that emotionally this guy's
obviously been very abused he has uh he
has a dark past he's got a did a lot of
abandonment abuse and neglect in his in
his in his life so there's kind of that
dark underbelly that that's why someone
sees the world away so you can't you
can't put stuff like that on from the
outside and just be like a blustery I
didn't want to be like a blustery old
I'm a blustery old cop hey bucum shut
down there get to evidence you know I I
wanted to like really find him okay
every week I'm up I got a jam my guns
jammed so yeah so that was interesting I
don't really I don't know I don't really
have a technique it really depends on
the role that I'm doing there was a part
I'd well you want to send this guy work
I mean you know I give a lot of secrets
away we don't you maybe I need to go to
the guy he's expensive yeah yeah I'm
$400
yeah and lighter exactly good luck it's
probably not justified for you to
sketches anyway but I mean you mentioned
it sounds like this is a maybe a
calculated move
how you're seeing in your history with
Dwight yeah what what's your current
relationship with Dwight as a character
you know I feel like on my tombstone
it's gonna say here lies the guy who
played Dwight you know I think I'm
always gonna be known as Dwight it's
it's gonna be Who I am I'm totally at
peace with that I get it
I am I knew that as soon as the office
took off and yeah I'm I'm happy that
Dwight was put to bed I'm happy that the
Dwight spin-off didn't work out and
wasn't picked up by NBC because I
wouldn't want to still be playing that
same character ultimately and I'm happy
to be moving on now were you part you
know the the story goes that the cast
got together and said hey let's let's
listen this show is is that is that
that's that's that's pretty true I don't
know that NBC would have continued but
the cast that all the leads of the cast
were kind of like this make sure there's
our last season and make sure every
episode really builds to a great ending
and let's do it right and let's um let's
bring in all the previous characters and
let's have a big parade and Scranton and
and do our final season the way it
really should be done and but the fact
that it became the final season was kind
of a groundswell from the young C actors
yeah and and I think that you know Greg
Daniels was the only one that was kind
of like um really sure is there a way to
continue the show maybe without some
view or a new cast of characters he had
a lot of like thoughts in his head and
he's a great guy and very loyal to us
but he was just thinking that he just
didn't really completely want to give it
up but you know so we put a lot of work
in that final season and then no one
really watched it and it's it it's a
really good season like the final like
five or six episodes of our final season
or as good as anything we had ever done
but Emma was like oh so much better when
Steve was yeah so it was a lot of that
and our finale was great I thought
we want to talk about the period of time
between you know when they office ended
and then now
Backstrom because you've done a lot of
interesting things that sort of have
some overlap with our world okay it's
you know specifically talking about
SoulPancake yeah and I remember seeing
that happened it was a part of a bigger
movement where some traditional
celebrities were coming in and we're
like oh well it was the original YouTube
fund right and guys like us we're like
it's is it we we've had our party it's
over real talented people are coming
into the space well traditionally I mean
triggers for media you got and NBA stars
like Shaq yeah yeah Amy Poehler had a
channel yeah yeah a lot of name people
had Jeff we wanted rain well rain will
cease in the memory how did that come
about was this a kind of thing that like
you were a fan of YouTube videos or was
somebody like ring you got to get in on
this online thing that's cash cow right
they're throwing around millions of
dollars they were they and that's of
yeah that's her if that's the answer so
we were scrambling to find our identity
what SoulPancake was we started remember
as a website to discuss life's big
questions and that was fun for a while
but it didn't really take off it didn't
really go anywhere so we made an app
that went with it and that didn't really
go anywhere then we did a book and that
was good it was a best-seller but and we
were just kind of struggling for
identity what's next for SoulPancake we
we have this mission as we I mean I'm me
and the founders there's really four of
us me and the guy started with Devin
Gondry and then his wife gol Ruiz Lucina
who still works there and our current
CEO Shabnam Megara be who I think you
guys know her or met her over email yeah
okay she's awesome she's super super
awesome and the other to suck the just
kidding so we were like what do we do we
have this great mission we have people
behind us we we know that we're know
we're on to something we want to do
uplifting content that's not sentimental
and treacly and stupid we wanted to do
something edgy and cool and funny and
outrageous but also makes the world a
better place and it's philosophy it's
part spirituality it's all about
creativity and
being an artist and expressing yourself
and so you know that we were scrambling
for money and there's no your tube is
giving out money for channels and we're
like what about that we'd already done
some videos for The Oprah Winfrey
Network and they were very popular they
were like the most popular thing on that
that whole dumb network and then so
we're like yeah let's let's go down here
so we just came up with a bunch of show
ideas based on our philosophy and our
worldview and we pitched it and went
great and and then really we're so
grateful to that experienced anti
YouTube and the YouTube channel
phenomenon thing because that's where we
found our voice in our identity and our
YouTube channel has taken off and we
really see ourselves more of a media
company so we you know we produce videos
either for a YouTube channel for
television or for commercials and they
have a certain you know magic mojo in
them and you've got involved personally
I mean hosting a few though shows and
yeah I am so my show is metaphysical
milkshake and now you know that YouTube
money is dried up so we are trying to
find other ways to fund what we like you
know how that goes it's a crazy it's a
crazy business the the YouTube game the
YouTube channel game and I mean how much
of yourself are you able to to put into
SoulPancake the channel at this point
you know with with the new show and
everything else that I assume you got
going on with your life
are you watching every video that's on
the channel are you i watch most of the
videos on the channel I once I watch
every single one but I've really stepped
back over the last year and I was very
involved early on in in the shows and
giving notes on the cuts and who you
know casting Candice here and giving her
a show thank you the little girl from
Ohio that you stole from us and you know
I was very involved in doing a lot of
promotion for it trying to get the
viewers trying to get like my Twitter
followers to head over to the YouTube
and and watch some of our videos and
subscribe and stuff like that but now
it's going gangbusters
Shabnam our CEO she's just awesome and
running it and and it's we're moving to
a from our lame space to a really cool
oh yeah - on the Miren we're in
Hollywood yeah you're the wrong straight
a seedy side of the hill now a an
interesting thing about doing any sort
of content that has any kind of
spiritual theme
I mean we've noticed that anytime
anybody senses that you're making some
sort of religious statement or statement
about anything metaphysical that just
starts like the YouTube argument in the
comments it's just and they can be just
most inane arguments but if you a
religious conversation and your yourse
watch the comments equals troubling you
you basically in one sense you've
started a conversation around spiritual
themes on YouTube a place where there's
not a lot of mature conversation about
spiritual themes like I have used like
what's your experience with that you're
like oh well yeah well well let's back
up a little bit because you've thrown
out a lot of words yeah so you throw out
spiritual than religious then
metaphysical and they're all very
different and there really depends on
how you define them so religious we
don't do anything religious on our
channel so it's not religious it's not
about religion its spiritual in this in
a sense yes but what how do you define
everyone to find spirituality different
I mean some people it's like talking to
the ghosts and the beyond some people
it's crystals and yoga classes some
people it's their Christian faith some
people it's kind of Oprah and Deepak
Chopra and kind of new agey podcasts and
stuff like everyone has a very different
thing like we define spirituality
differently so it's spirituality is just
anything that's beyond the material
that's it and that creativity is and
being an artist is the main part of
being spiritual so it's it's expressing
yourself and it's making cool and it's
making the world awesome and being of
service to people and making people
laugh and uplifting their spirits and
telling beautiful stories that make you
remember what it is to be a human being
and connecting people and building
bridges and having fun along the way
like that's
spiritual it doesn't have to go down any
kind of sentimental road or new-age Road
or religious road and that's the kind of
the the juicy stuff that we explore on
SoulPancake well in in and I guess
that's just it is regardless of how well
you state it and how well you present it
I mean 75% of all YouTube commenters are
still gonna misunderstand and think that
you're saying something that they want
to be offended by just then causes a
Carly's opinionated about yeah right up
on you guys hate your YouTube comments
no I'm just saying that okay okay here's
an example so we got we got invited to
the White House two months ago as part
of a the it's on us campaign it's on us
campaign the campaign to address sexual
assault on college campuses
okay and so the Obama administration has
been doing this thing where they get
youtubers and they want they want more
of it less of it I think less it was it
was confusing in the meeting I just want
to make sure we're on the same and we
were like this is a cool cool
opportunity and we're going to go and
part of this is going to be how can we
be a part of this movement sure you know
things like well I'm gonna change my
Twitter icon to the it's on us campaign
icon but hey I list tell the story of us
going to the White House because there
were some funny things happening we
thought we were gonna get to shake hands
with the president but it turned out we
got like a foot from him and we missed
this opportunity and some weird stuff
happened but he didn't give us a foot we
were that far away yes we we told this
story hand you his foot right when we
tried to shake his hand right you're a
foot away I mean you couldn't get right
last when I had at home you couldn't
close I had an awkward moment with a
secret security a Secret Service guy
security yeah and it was like I got into
staredown and I was did you get shake
hands with him at least nope but just
telling a story yeah and also plug in
the campaign which you would think that
reducing sexual assault is a everybody
can get behind
sabore - kind of yeah
I uh I had hope I had hardened and noble
cause and still and still you got a lot
of haters they were just like what would
you guys even want to meet this guy
and I'm just like and we weren't even
making a political statement sure but
they wanted to make it wouldn't matter
if it was a Democrat or a Republican in
the White House this is a great campaign
they invited you to be part of it and
sure yeah right and I mean we observe
across YouTube that the same thing
happens if there's anything that okay if
there's anything that people can
interpret as something in the religious
realm then they're gonna they're gonna
start throwing their baggage out there
sure that's not that didn't happen on
you know what I'll tell you something on
on our YouTube on our SoulPancake calm
there's definitely a lot of arguments
there but it's still pretty civil and on
our channel you know we just um I guess
we kick off those people or something
but it's pretty civil you know people
get it's pretty simple people get along
for the most part there's a we try and
create a just a really positive command
miss fear and community around
SoulPancake ins this is not the place to
go and say there's no God or say you're
going to hell or or all whatever the you
know that yeah the black and white
diatribe of the day is or right Obama or
Romney or whatever yeah so yeah it's
been we've been really lucky that way
honestly check out our comments I mean
go look they're there they're pretty
they're pretty civil I mean that's
encouraging I think that's a that's a
testimony to the tone that you guys set
mm-hmm and even though the there's so
many different things that you that you
hit on but there is that there's an
across-the-board tone that you know what
you're gonna get with soul pancake that
it's gonna be that's gonna be thoughtful
it's gonna be sincere it's gonna be
there's a positive motivation behind
that then activates you yeah to the same
end yeah it can be like kid presidents a
douche bag yeah yeah yeah well you
you're you're a dick why as if like the
channel that brought you kid president
is gonna be that
yep you know I would I'd love to go back
and you know in your story and then kind
of derive what brings you to a point to
want to create this kind of community in
this kind of channel we know that your
bahá'í faith is something that you're
very vocal about well yeah so I'm a
member of the Baha'i faith and my
religious faith is really important to
me and it's a part of my life it's part
of my daily life and it means a lot to
me and there's a lot of ideas in the
Baha'i faith that I try and bring
forward in my work so I don't really I
never want to be any kind of Baha'i
spokesperson or a Hollywood behind
spokesperson or anything like that and I
really don't want to do that but people
ask I'll talk about it and it's you know
here's things I love I love Radiohead
I love the Seattle Seahawks I love the
Baha'i faith you know I love sushi and
if you ask me about these things I'm
going to talk about the things that are
part of my life you know some I just not
really shy about it and a lot of people
are gonna think I'm weird or in some
weird cult or that there's something
freaky going on there and there's really
not and you know but there people are
just gonna think whatever they're gonna
think and no matter what your faith I
think that there are certain important
thing I think just making the world a
better place and uplifting people and
serving people that are less fortunate
than yourself is something whether
you're an atheist or an agnostic or
Christian or Baha'i or whatever or
Muslim like those are things we can all
get behind and that's what we should all
be doing regardless of our beliefs oh is
SoulPancake has some inspiration from
the Baha'i faith there's certain things
about SoulPancake that we were inspired
to bring to life like that idea of
creativity being a form of prayer of
making art as a as a as a sacred and a
beautiful thing the individual
investigation of truth finding the truth
for yourself engaging in life's big
questions that's a core tenet of the
Baha'i faith of not just taking what
your parents believed or what your
culture believes or but really finding
the truth for yourself so some of these
things
have like definitely influenced
influenced soul pancake but it really is
just ultimately like I believe and I
think that most people believe no matter
what their belief system that we should
just try and make the world a better
place and we just front try and find
ways to do that and as I became a
celebrity you know a lot of doors opened
and I was like oh here's an opportunity
let's let's try and do something really
cool on the Internet that brings people
together get some talking about big
ideas inspires them uplifts them
celebrates art creativity and
awesomeness and let's do it in a way
that is not treacly and stupid and
syrupy and dumb so that's that's really
what it was about and you described the
Baha'i faith as faith of unity right so
how do you engage with all the
individuals out there I mean when we a
lot of people say well religion is the
number one calls for disunity in the
world today right we see it all the time
whether you're talking about a Christian
who says that it's you agree with me or
you're going to hell or it's a Muslim
who says convert or die or all the
horrible things that we see happening so
how do you engage with other people of
other faiths when you're trying to say
hey know you're a part of something
bigger but I know that and they're like
well no I'm not well
first of all you just gotta ignore the
haters no matter where they come from
whether it's an atheist or a born-again
and like I just said it's about finding
that commonality you know we work with
Muslim crew members at SoulPancake one
of our top employees is very devout in
her Christian faith we had a channel
manager who was a devout atheist you
know but all of these people wanted to
make a difference and it's about finding
that commonality and I get it you know
people think that organized religion is
it causes much more disunity and and
pain in the world then it brings solace
and for the most part I agree with that
and it's it's really awful what's being
done in the name of religion and it it's
sickening but we have to as a as a
culture and as a species not throw the
baby out with the bathwater because
there are some spiritual truths that
Mohammed broad that Jesus brought that
the Buddha brought that
bahá'u'lláh who is the founder of the
Baha'i faith that he brought and these
kind of basic true spiritual truths can
really can help heal the planet you know
they they're there they're a healing
message of love and unity underneath all
of this rancor and and book that you
read about in the paper all the time in
fact I just read remember that
best-selling memoir of that six year old
it was in a coma and went to heaven and
floor Fralick but he made it all up he
made it all up dude made it all up
I don't know did he do it with his
parents or was he just I don't know I
just saw the article today - yeah I just
popped up on my phone I was like hold
how old was he when he wrote it I think
six and he liked to hold it to his
parents yeah and then I frolicked with
the Angels and then they took me to see
Jesus and then we went over here and we
saw God and we said hi when a movie was
made about or there was another kid that
I don't know there's like at least two
books should have done to deter kids
brought this into the pod but you hear
stuff like that - and you're just like
oh man come on this is all bull so I
don't know well how it how is it how is
the Baha'i faith different there's a way
more handsome in person
oh yeah well I could say the same about
you yeah just be more specific we listen
to the USC commencement speech yeah we
we weren't students we just watched it
oh yeah yeah a couple hours ago it's a
big youtube video I mean you talk about
eliminating desire which is a Buddhist
principle but huh so I was curious how
the Baha'i faith was different than
Buddhism the Baha'i faith has different
than Buddhism because the highs believe
that there's a God first of all and
Buddhism there's hints at something
higher but the Buddha didn't really talk
about God so much and that's a longer
discussion about why that was but um the
highs believe that God and there's only
one God and that all the religious
faiths worship this one God and that God
sends down every once in a while these
divine teachers or divine healers really
that are there to uplift mankind and
teach them these spiritual truths and
that's you know the Mohammed and and
Jesus and the Buddha and Krishna and
Abraham and Moses and these and now the
highs believe that Baha Allah is the
most recent one of these divine teachers
and they bring a message for Humanity -
- for their spiritual healing to that
particular people in that particular
time you know Muhammad's message was for
the warring tribes of the Arabian
Peninsula in the year 600 you know
there's still a number of universal
truths there and what he spoke that are
that are really beautiful if you really
look at the Quran but a lot of it was
for his audience you got to know your
audience right your podcasters so
believe that by Allah's teachings so
house by faith different buddha we
believe that by how Allah's teachings
are the way to help heal the world and
there's in its current incarnation its
current iterate state you know you know
in this modern world and that unity is
the key word word in unity of the races
equality of men and women universal
education elimination of prejudice
Aeolus re seeing the unity and in in all
of the religions eliminating extremes of
wealth and poverty as we see more and
more that you know that's a spiritual
teaching in the Baha'i faith eliminating
the extremes of wealth and poverty but
not through like communism but through
but spiritually you know tackling this
issue okay so the Baha'u'llah
Baha'u'llah yeah hi oh well I know it's
a tough it's a tough one here bah ha ha
ha like Baja Peninsula ha hula-hula
bahá'u'lláh they
you go and the name that mean name means
the glory of God in in Persian is he is
he like is he hanging out in Agoura
Hills or where where is he right he is
in the gore Hills he's he's in my
basement
he lived in he lived in Persia in the
mid 1800s and he died in like 1890 or so
okay yeah but Baha'i faith spread from
there he was tortured by the Muslim
authorities and tens of thousands of
bizarre killed by the Muslims in the
early days and he was banished from
country to country he ended up going to
like Syria and where Jordan is and then
over to Turkey and then down to Egypt
and then he was in Palestine where he
spent his whole life in prison but now
the Baha'i faith is very it's the second
most widespread religion in the world
there's about five or six million
adherents around and you know but I hope
that people have positive experience
applies but highs aren't allowed to
proselytize I'm not allowed to try and
convert anybody oh that's a law to not
try and convert anybody Oh
that being said we talk about it like
I'm doing right now people interested in
checking it out that's totally cool but
we don't like go to people's doors no
Pam grab them and shake pamphlets in
their face or anything like that so got
it
no your parents are Baha'i faith
yeah raised Baha'i faith I was raising
the Baha'i faith my parents are kind of
hippie bohemian types in Seattle and
then when I went to New York City I was
20 years old I went to acting school and
I basically rebelled against everything
I'd grown up with and I became an
atheist and it's something happen or it
was just that you know I just didn't
want any morality
I didn't yeah I didn't want any morality
I was angry at my parents and I just
rebelled against all of it and so I you
know I wanted to drink and use drugs and
I wanted to have sex and I wanted to be
a bohemian and Greenwich Village in the
80s and I went to acting school and dyed
my hair black and smoked filterless
cigarettes and talked about bertolt
brecht a lot and and so I was really
annoying how long did that phase less
hmm ten years for reals
so I really was had nothing to do with
any kind of spirituality or faith and
and I really just focused on being an
actor and kind of in a weird way theatre
and acting became my religious faith so
I really thought that we could change
the world if we did really important
cool theater so we could do the right
Chekhov play in the right church
basement to the right 14 people that we
could like blow their minds
but you were but so you were you didn't
become a bad person you just started
doing things that were kind of outlawed
but you still wanted to make a
difference but it was through the power
of theater that's it that's exactly
right yeah I wasn't yeah I wasn't no I
wasn't a bad person I was an annoying
person I'm probably still an annoying
person yeah a little bit so there's that
did you become hopeless yeah so that was
I really did that was um you know I was
in all of us and so this one I talked
about that at the USC speech about
happiness I feel like I learned
firsthand that we think about happiness
as like oh if I get this then I'll be
happy if I get X Y & Z those puzzle
pieces fit together then I'll be happy
and basically I had everything I'd ever
wanted which was I was a working actor
playing great roles working with great
directors in New York City living in New
York City I had a beautiful girlfriend
now my wife holiday Rhine horn and she
was awesome and here it was I had I had
the woman I had this career that I'd
always wanted I was living in in the
coolest place on earth and I just was
really unhappy I just found you know
just at night I was just waking up super
unhappy and unmotivated and I was like
what is going on and it was kind of that
deep thing of like is there's gotta be
some other meaning to this I can't just
you know cuz I realize pretty soon you
realize you'd do any art like oh I'm not
gonna change the world with the theater
I mean I'm gonna do some really cool
plays and people are gonna be jazzed I'm
gonna do some really plays and people
are gonna be pissed that they had to
come see me in them and and and so I
realized that the truth was not to be
found there and that's kind of when I
went on a spiritual journey of sorts and
read a lot of spiritual books and holy
books and did a lot of
hating and so that was an interesting
time did you did you maintain a dialogue
with your your parents at that time
about I didn't really per issues I
didn't really talk to them about it no
no but there was a moment when you said
I'm back to yourself yeah well I god
this is a much this is a very long story
I didn't know we're gonna get so heavy
in this podcast how we're gonna joke
around about the new Star Wars movie
well something you know we'll get there
okay no I mean this is you're digging on
this oh you're like let's dig this rich
stuff okay I mean I know you're just
like that six-year-old it's you're
making it up as you go I'm buying the
book okay I saw angels yeah man I
basically I was reading a book about
Native American spirituality and it
described the Lakota Sioux definition of
God as one can Tonka and this idea that
God is it's everywhere and it's within
us and without us and coursing through
all of nature got it beyond time and
beyond space it's all loving that is
reflected through nature and in the four
directions and our ancestors are part of
this experience in animals and and I was
reading about one Kentucky knows and and
the name literally translates as the
great mystery
so the Lakota Sioux called God the great
mystery you know I was like wow I can
totally get with this and that kind of
led me back to God I went from like
atheist to agnostic and I was like I can
get with the great mystery I feel that
in my heart that there's something more
there's some higher purpose we're not
just a random assortment of molecules
who somehow gained consciousness on this
ball of mud up here and then when we die
what's just the end and then when the
earth blows up it's just this matter
floating around in space and I I just
really felt like there was something
more and that's kind of what led me to
read the holy books of the
world I read the Quran in the Bible and
I read the works of the Buddha and the
Dhammapada
the bhagavad-gita of Hinduism and I just
really dug in and then I and then I
found my way back to the Baha'i writings
and I read them again and I was like you
know I just this just makes sense to me
it just makes the most sense and you
know it was a long slow journey kind of
tiptoeing back but it's been it's been
it's been nice and it yeah and you
bailed on you been married 19 years Wow
yeah going on 20 well you know I mean so
going on 20's this has got to be like a
special celebration and you can't screw
this up what kind of expectations do you
have and does your wife have about stuff
like that is it like 20 ok we're going
to Italy
what cause I think that's what my wife
has already said yes my wife it's so
funny she like now like things mean a
lot like her birthday and anniversary we
never celebrated like Valentine's Day
that was never like a thing and now all
of a sudden it was kind of almost
started like last year like she's good
she I don't know I thought you got older
that stuff went away but and she said
live romantic crisis well yeah there's
not a crisis but I definitely once I
don't recommend that being irresponsible
honey you're just going through a
midlife romantic crazy
yeah but I'll be waiting on the other
side no birthdays anniversaries
Valentine's Day that's yeah it's it's
good it's it's almost 20 years we've
been together
been together 23 24 years old so it's
it's great I you know it's it's awesome
she's incredible person she's um a great
writer she wrote a book of short stories
and went to the Iowa Writers Workshop
and she's writing a novel right now and
she rides horses she does like dressage
riding and horses competes and stuff and
well you can do that kind of thing when
you when you live outside of town yeah
is that why you're out there in the like
the the Far Hills
yeah the way far end of the valley is
yeah there's horse country out there
well you know there's rednecks out there
too yeah we went to a Merle
Haggard concert at the Canyon Club oh
that's that's that's very close to my
house and we're huge Merle fans and
we've we've kind of developed a
connection with him and his son who's in
his band we've been fans forever so we
got invited to the to the concert at the
Canyon Club relationship goroh Hills
you've been right down the road candy
Club yeah been there yeah I saw that's
cool I saw Courtney Love there I saw X
there well when you see Merle there yeah
I want to see I mean you could you guys
you have the dinner it's like a dinner
theater yes yes did yet what you have
like this body you know what yeah we all
know he's got drinks because they were
like we're gonna find you a place and we
ended up they put us in the way back and
it was you know he was about to start
yeah but we're from you know rural North
Carolina so we're very familiar with
what a country bar looks like but I was
just like this is you know this is right
outside of town these you know for real
yeah okay but you're out there for your
wife to have the horses yeah and I'm
like you ride a horse I know no I like
the countryside tomb and we have like
owls and foxes we had boxes outside our
house not coyotes foxes but a fox in a
tree yeah whatever we have a zonkey
blink we have a donkey like personas on
a donkey we only donkey it's in our
backyard oh my goodness it's a it's a
horse in a think about it zebra and a
donkey yes yes what why do you need the
horse at all no there's no there's no
I'm sorry I said horse it's donkey zebra
mix Derek the donkey he lives at our
house what what does he do I mean he
eats and he eats how did you acquire an
a Derek kind of a deck can you take
pictures with him yeah you guys want to
come out absolutely I mean that's we're
to it yeah that's the name of the up
coming up yeah honky no how did you get
Derek what my lady where does one
acquire Wow okay did you breed him okay
my wife saw a donkey she fell in love
with it she said I want a donkey I was
like yes dear whatever you want dear of
course dear
so she
two donkeys no she went to zebras are us
calm I'm not kidding you lit right now
but I am NOT Oh will I'm not kidding
zebras are us calm Riverside California
and she plunked down like three grand
and they delivered a donkey to our house
and my son named him Derek now if I may
well imagine being the first donkey in
your group of donkeys to like to mount a
zebra I mean just think about what
you're thinking at Emma hi
you haven't seen sexy two zebra you guys
you haven't seen that video well it's
the stripes man just think about the
elation of this is working I think it's
working first of us is welcome to your
trusted source for zebras is it trusted
yeah for sale this is this a top menu
for sale what we do there's a donkey
grease for a photo op see for hire I'm
interested meet the herd meet the herd
at how much of the derek has stripes is
it just his legs just lift the leg as
the legs are stripy but his mane dipped
in zebra a little yet exactly a perfect
description but his mane is um zebra
esque but he's got a big donkey head
what's his temperament we should have
started with this he's been really sweet
um he was really sweet but now he's kind
of being a dick like to me he's - he's
like territorial you know like feed him
and he like pushed me out of the way to
get to the bucket and get his head in
there and kind of like swing his butt
around he won't like kick at me but it's
just kind of like bullying so we have to
do some training a Sish I mean my mom
has five donkeys yeah and once I tell
her about this donkey thing I knew they
existed but I never brought it up to her
and she's gonna just you know want one
of nuts but donkeys are sweet mostly
right she's got some mean ones and they
have to be separate you can't have two
jacks in the same pen because they'll
you know yeah they'll fight yeah and
they're partial like you can't miss you
human jacks
like Jack Black Jack Bauer could never
be in there that never works
I can't think of one ago he was up for
the role Wow did I know that Wow
fantastic did you say fact as a
testament to Dwight just that I think it
was subconscious no it was it wasn't
intentional but yeah but it was
definitely it was their shy pologize no
it was great I love it Oh fact we won
Lopez tonight I see you got the mug oh
yeah I was hoping you would notice that
we were both on Lopez - no really yeah
other thing that unites us yes that was
let's talk about how great that was I
liken it to when I first made love to
cebra you know you're really excited but
it was a little confusing like this is
working yeah he's really energetic he's
really into the audience was the
audience is loud it was and it was our
first ever late-night they're not like
normally they're not like that we'd go
on and like hey thanks George the
audience is like and there's a lot of
them it was a big it was a big plate was
scary it was scary yeah I was not a good
first experience the shows not on
anymore I don't know if you I know I
noticed but the mugs still works lives
on it's a beautiful mug do you have any
other animals because we should have we
should have started and showed up with
this awesome
we really don't take it at the time you
don't add it you know it's just this is
we don't get it's we you have any other
ones we have a miniature horse with - oh
you got to understand what just happened
how many what I can't believe this
miniature horse no lie is links favorite
animal so much so that we have miniature
horse Monday on our Instagram know every
Monday can I buy a ticket to your house
yes and we have tried teen hundred
dollars we have tried many a times
effect we were trying to get a chariot
pulled by a miniature horses recently
into we were told that that was inhumane
but is that inhumane I don't know that's
what the Humane Society told us it's
inhumane to have miniature horse pulling
they're like oh they can't grow their
miniatures they can do that if we were
like it's a wheels and he's like oh
they're as big as a donkey
you donkeys could pull a chariot well it
could be a small chariot with a small
person on it childs what do you have the
chariot pull around that kid made up the
story about the Angels Oh Brigid this is
really gonna be fun when we come out
yeah
I am so inviting my so invited yourself
mission accomplished what's the
miniatures his name Reba
she's a little she's a little feisty
little gal well and what is what utility
to see serve because they can be seen i
ponies some people she does come in the
house she has shoes what she had
miniature horseshoes my wife puts on and
brings her in the house
does she like it in there she looks
around she goes over to the refrigerator
yeah and she wants carrots oh here's
your nose there's carrots in there great
um why your son can ride Reba no you
can't not you can't drive Derek or Reba
they they're they're too difficult okay
my wife likes him she loves animals and
she's also got some horses and it's fun
man it's it's fun and you know I get I I
don't touch him really I don't really
have much to do with well this sounds
like Swiss Family Robinson at your home
it's a little bit yeah it's a little bit
well fun it's a fun place well what else
any other odd animals and just some fish
and some guinea pigs yeah least got a
couple of hermit crabs it's a sore
subject because well I don't anymore you
have a zero now yeah you ate him well he
neglected one oh sorry Mike it's my kids
yeah he was left in charge when they
went back to North Carolina and one of
them died Oh oh yeah it's not good
that's not good that's why I said sore
subject I'd rather not talk about it
mm-hmm okay but this one if we just go
yeah if we just go back to the zonkey
just go back to the zonkey energy to
wrap up yeah just we don't have to talk
about it let's just i'm just feeling
that energy yeah as a wrap-up
that's close to the hermit crab
everybody that really yeah yeah I took
the crab writer of the show this room
yeah and this this pathetic room let's
bring it all the way back to
killing this sad pathetic room in
Burbank that you're leaving and
apologizing for yeah
donkeys donkeys are fun yeah he makes a
crazy sound he goes like this it's got a
little ring of ten in it it is like
Planet of the Apes just like the yeah
the orangutan is in Planet of the Apes
well we'll let you know where we're
coming out you can my Lopez mug until
until then we'll send up a flare I'll
take it in trade Lopez Tonight mug and
you can visit the donkey okay deal yes
deal rhett and Link thanks for having me
on your show yeah well thanks for being
here and there you have it our ear
biscuit with Rainn Wilson super
appreciative that rain came and hung out
with us and let us get to know him in
this dimmed lighting atmosphere
you should let reign know on Twitter
what do you think tweet at him Rainn
Wilson of course there's two ends in
rain and at the end well no it's in the
middle of Rainn Wilson at the end of
rain are a double Rai double N Wilson
yeah I think they know what I was saying
yeah I I know what you're saying to
anyway just tweet at him and tell him
what you thought of this ear biscuit use
hashtag ear biscuits I gotta say I it
made me feel a little bit better about
myself when I found out that Rainn
Wilson knew who we were in 2009 was
making phone calls like yeah that's a
thrill and I'm gonna add something to
that right now
I'm I'm beginning to realize that he
there could have been even more to that
that he didn't know there's a connection
here right think about this okay he sees
the red house furniture commercial and
he said that he shares it with all of us
people says somebody needs to represent
these people in the industry mm-hmm what
happened to us totally independent or
was it we started getting calls from
production company
which eventually led to us turning our
local commercials on our on our YouTube
channel into the show on IFC getting
getting the IFC show which led to us
moving to LA all of that happen in the
most significant phone call that we got
was from readily which is the production
company which was also behind what shell
the office so I I don't know if he
obviously didn't realize it we didn't
realize it right when he said it but now
I'm well we just got a call Todd is yeah
we could ask Todd is rain Todd is the
producer that reached out to us he
worked for revelry and helped to produce
commercial Kings was it rains email
about our red house furniture commercial
that got the ball rolling with revelry
which led to us getting the television
show which led to basically everything
the fact which led to this moment right
here this conversation with Rainn Wilson
does it all go back to Rick and I now is
that what you're saying like the circle
is complete well no I'm just saying we
need to we need to go back to reign and
tell him hey thank you even more because
you may very well be the missing link in
us getting our television show maybe we
shouldn't call Todd because if he's like
no no no then it ruins it it isn't it's
not as romantic let's just let's just
assume that the reason that we got a
television show is because of Rainn
Wilson Thank You Rainn Thank You Rainn
and thank you for introducing us to
zebras are us calm yeah let me talk a
lot of time there
talk about life changing I think we're a
but he's about to send our life in a
totally new trajectory of zorse care or
zonkey I wasn't eight they sell sources
all I want is a couple of horses a
couple of donkeys and a couple of zebras
of various genders and I want to breathe
donkeys and horses that's where the
money's at the money's not in just you
know having one having one it's making
more it's making more we can make as
many zombies as you want
in fact that's our name of our website
all the donkeys you want calm all the
sakis you want for Less doc okay we're
gonna undercut zebras are us okay
look guys please leave us a review on
iTunes it certainly helps also you can
comment along with the conversation on
SoundCloud give that a shot and we'll
see you again next week we will be on
the backs of two zombies for another
biscuit
[Music]
[Music]